So today we'll discuss what meditation
is and how exactly it relates to
emotional wellbeing.
Indeed,
we've seen a surge of interest in this
concept of mindfulness and meditation in
recent years.
We see articles here in the New York
Times talking about how meditation may
actually change the brain.
We also see articles here is
suggesting and the Huffington Post,
that you can unlock the
power of meditation to feel
happier and more at ease or,
and the La Times. This is your mind
on meditation, that if you meditate,
you'll engage in less mind wandering and
do get engaged in more doing or living
your life.
So it's not surprising that mindfulness
and meditation more generally has gained
this exploding momentum and be when
widely advertised in the media and popular
press even more so.
There's a sense in which people feel that
we ought to be teaching mindfulness in
this digital age,
that this is an antidote to help solve
our current conundrum of being. So my,
you know, so engaged, uh, in
mind wandering, so distracted,
not focused in the present moment
that we need to teach mindfulness,
that it's not only an option, but it's
actually something that's a dire need.
So with all this hype about mindfulness,
both in the scientific realm
and in the popular media rum,
we have to ask ourself what is mindfulness
and how exactly does it relate to our
emotional health?
So today what we're going to be thinking
about is what is mindfulness and what
does it mean to actually meditate?
And also how can we exactly be
mindful of our own emotions?
And if we're mindful of our own emotions,
in what way might this actually
change our emotional health?
So when we think about this,
the Buddha thought and deed that we,
mindfulness indeed does promote and, uh,
not only promote emotional understanding,
but promote increased health.
So he would say to enjoy good health,
to bring true happiness to one's family,
to bring peace to all one must first
discipline and control one's own mind
through these sort of contemplated
practices like meditation and mindfulness.
So today we're going to start our second
series on emotional health by delving
into the realm of mindfulness
and asking ourselves,
can we really accept our
emotions in the present moment?
We're going to do so by first,
um,
approaching the idea of mindfulness
and trying to understand, well,
what is mindfulness in the first place?
And once we get an operational definition
of mindfulness or review some key
empirical findings that have associated
mindfulness with emotional wellbeing,
then we'll conclude with our takeaway
questions and expert interview.
So first let's ask ourselves, you may
have heard of mindfulness in the news.
You may have heard friends or
colleagues talk about mindfulness,
but what exactly is it?
So when we think of mindfulness,
it's a form of really cognitive training
aimed at learning how and where we
guide one's attention.
So this involves maintaining awareness
of attention from one moment to the next
and gently but firmly escorting it back
to the initial target object when the
mind becomes distracted.
So the point of mindfulness meditation
is really to train the mind in a way to
make it stronger, to get the
muscles you know, bigger and better.
And faster to be more stable and let
it disengage from our typical more
automatic thought processes.
As you can see here,
these are what I think of as four
core components in most discussions of
mindfulness.
So we can think of these as the four
critical ingredients of mindfulness.
So it includes awareness, sustained
attention, focus on the present moment,
and nonjudgmental acceptance.
So let me walk you through these four
elements of mindfulness right now,
just defining them briefly
and discussing them in turn.
So I'll start with the first
component of awareness.
So what is awareness and a
mindfulness oriented approach?
So awareness has really defined as the
conscious knowledge of one's experience.
It includes conscious knowledge of one's
body sensations such as breathing, once,
thoughts and emotions,
and external events and sounds.
What about sustained attention?
What does it mean?
As the Buddhist said to really discipline
one's mind to really gain sort of
control over your attention
and observe where it takes you,
sustaining it in the present moment.
So by sustained attention,
this is really focusing on
placing one's attention on,
on an ongoing stream of
internal and external stimuli.
So it involves bringing attention
to the target of observation.
And when we get distracted,
having your attention gently brought
back to the original targeted focus.
So often the attention will
be focused on one's breathing.
So bringing one's breath to your
attention. And when you get distracted,
your mind wanders to other thoughts
about what you want to have for lunch and
what you're worried about tomorrow
and what's coming up next week.
Gently bringing back your
attention to your breath.
The third component is this sort
of focus on the present moment.
And by that what we're talking about
is directing one's attention with or
without effort to internal and external
phenomena at each moment of awareness.
So this is a distinct concept
from being preoccupied,
from fantasizing,
and also from ruminating.
So here you're literally just focusing
your attention on whatever is occurring
in the present moment.
It may be internal,
your thoughts and maybe something external
and the environment and you're just
letting that happen in the present moment.
Just noticing and observing each moment
in the present and being fully aware of
it.
So the final and fourth component often
discuss in definitions of mindfulness is
nonjudgmental acceptance.
So by nonjudgmental acceptance,
what this is focusing on is really
experiencing the thoughts, sensations,
and events as they are at the moment.
They enter one's consciousness without
judging them as either good or bad,
or as desirable or undesirable.
And really what you're doing here
is you're allowing all experiences,
whether good or bad, to arise without
trying to change control or of white.
Then this applies both to concrete
experiences such as sensory pain,
as well as abstract things such as
having thoughts or feelings of rejection.
So acceptance really allows individuals
to appreciate the experience,
even if it includes things
like negative valuations.
Thoughts such as I'm a failure.
And what it suggests is that you can
simply embrace these thoughts without
trying to suppress them,
distort them,
or sort of escape from
them through fantasy.
So you're simply accepting whatever
thoughts and feelings arise with a
nonjudgmental stance towards them.
So what I'd like to do now is to think
about these four elements and to really
highlight the point that all of these
four elements are required and important
in order to achieve a full moment of
mindfulness. So I think of it this way,
um, if we have mindfulness in the center,
in order to have it, we need awareness,
sustained attention,
nonjudgmental acceptance,
and the focus on the present moment that
it's all these four elements that need
to come together to have this full circle
and embrace and sort of give rise to
an experience of mindfulness.
Now,
interestingly,
recent models that have been proposed
and work by myself and some of my
colleagues here at Yale have really tried
to think about what is the mechanism
or process that underlies mindfulness?
What is it doing for our emotional life?
Does it d automatize our emotional life?
So we know that much of our mental life
is largely automatic. It's Ha habitual,
right? It's literally spontaneous, quick,
and even happening before you would
realize it in your own conscious and
awareness of times.
And the process that my colleagues
and I have argued here is that what
mindfulness does is it helps sort
of break us of our habitual modes of
responding and really focus on
d automatizing emotional life,
making one more aware of our attentional
processes and thoughts so that we can
notice and even change them to ultimately,
you know,
promote enhanced emotional wellbeing.
So what you see here in this figure is
that mindfulness promotes these four
components we talked about earlier.
Awareness, attention, present moment,
focus and nonjudgmental acceptance.
And that each of these four critical
components of mindfulness gives rise to
what we think of as d automatizing
processes. So wearness promotes, um,
you know, a discontinuation of
automatic inference processing.
This is from literature looking
at priming and stereotyping.
Increased and sustained attention enables
us to enhance our cognitive control
over our emotions,
both at,
at the attentional control level
and gives us cognitive flexibility.
Being focused on the present
moment helps facilitate metta.
Metacognitive insight helps us engage
in decentering and sort of less or non
elaborative processing.
And finally,
nonjudgmental acceptance prevents us from
engaging in things that would take us
away from the actual emotion we're
having, right? It, it actually makes us,
enforces us to be exposed to
the emotions in their raw form,
preventing us from suppressing
the emotions, distorting them,
and even escaping from them.
All of these d automatizing
features ultimately produce,
promote adaptive self regulation leading
to desirable individual and societal
health outcomes.
Now we've talked a lot about mindfulness,
but really what does it actually like?
So let me briefly guide you
through a meditation exercise,
just walking through some of the common
steps that you would see often occurring
in these exercises with a
focus on the breath. So, uh,
I'll have you follow these instructions.
So first I'd like you to take a moment
to adjust your position in front of your
laptop computer student probably,
and gently close your eyes
and settle into your body.
Okay.
If you're sitting in sure that your
body is upright and comfortable for you,
okay.
Now in your own way,
take a few moments and try
to simply relax your body.
Okay.
Once you've done that, perhaps you'll
feel the muscles in your body softening,
maybe even loosening,
relaxing and releasing.
Okay?
Just simply letting go
and perhaps even taking a deeper breath.
Taking a couple deep breaths.
As you breathe out,
notice that natural feeling of relaxing
and releasing a little more with each
out breath.
Remember to just simply let,
go.
Try to pay attention
to any sounds you hear.
Just listening with a gentle curiosity,
letting the sounds come and go,
not needing to judge them,
okay?
As you bring awareness to your breath,
notice what sensations there are as
you breathe in and as you breathe out,
feel the air,
touch your nostrils.
Feel the slight movement
of your chest and stomach.
If you notice your attention wandering
or becoming distracted, you're not alone.
We all do this,
but you can simply bring your
attention back to your breath.
Okay?
Being aware of this breath, being
aware of what it is to be breathing in,
being aware of what it
is to be breathing out.
So that was a very brief introduction to
the kinds of exercises one would do in
a guided meditation exercise. Um, it
would be done for a much longer period.
But just to give you the sense
that you're picking a sensation,
often the breath and focusing
on it in the present moment,
in a nonjudgmental attitude,
simply focusing on it.
And if your mind wanders or gets
distracted, which it does for all of us,
simply noticing it, observing
it, and bringing your
attention back to the breath.
Now if you're interested in doing more
of these kinds of exercises, UCLA,
the mindfulness awareness
research center has some fat,
fantastic free meditation. PODCASTS
is one place to get started. Um,
you can see here they have
different exercises focused on, um,
but the breathing meditation
similar to what we did today, um,
as well as meditation,
focus on different kinds of,
of things such as working with
difficulties, loving kindness, um,
and breath sound and body. So we've talked
about the definition of mindfulness.
We've talked about potential mechanisms
underlying it such as d automatizing our
emotional life,
and briefly sort of got a glimpse into
what some of these exercises might look
like.
So now I want to turn to some of the
scientific and empirical evidence on how
mindfulness may be associated
with enhanced emotional wellbeing.
So first we've seen studies that have
shown that mindfulness meditation actually
is associated with decreased
emotional reactivity.
So this was a study done by Judson brewer
and colleagues comparing mindfulness
therapy to traditional
cognitive behavioral therapies.
And what they found here is we're
looking at self reported emotion.
Our mindfulness therapy group is in black.
And what you're seeing is that as a
function of engaging in this type of
mindfulness spaced, um,
treatment, individuals are
reporting reductions in anxiety,
sadness, anger, and fear.
So we're showing that indeed mindful
meditation seems to decrease the motion
activity,
especially for negative emotions.
Okay.
There's also been really an explosion of
work that was originally spearheaded by
Richie Davidson at Wisconsin and now
other colleagues such as heady Cobar and
others, looking at how mindfulness
meditation may actually change your brain.
So one of the original studies done in
2003 included an eight week randomized
controlled study in mindfulness meditation
as compared to a weightless control
group. These are all healthy
adults. At the outset.
And what they found is that those who are
assigned to the mindfulness meditation
group showed actual changes
in their brain activity.
So we saw increases and left hemispheric.
And as you may remember from our earlier
lectures on the emotion and brain,
when we see sort of lateralization with
relatively great activity in the left
hemisphere,
this has been associated with the
subjective experience of positive mood and
emotion.
There's been more recent studies also
looking at potential neuromechanisms
underlying mindfulness training,
showing that it alters the neural
expression of sadness. So here,
authors used in Fmri study to compare
neuro reactivity to a laboratory
provocations of sadness and those
who either underwent eight weeks of
mindfulness training or
waitlisted control group.
And what they found is that those who
are in the mindfulness training group
exhibited greater what they
called visceral and Somata
sensory activation in the
brain during sadness.
And that this pattern of neural
reactivity was associated with decreased
depression severity scores.
So what this suggests,
they argue is that mindfulness may
help sort of balance, um, this,
this intricate balance between emotions
and sensory networks and may actually
support a fuller portrait of both the
conceptual and body-based representations
of emotion.
And by doing so,
this may help actually reduce
vulnerability to depression.
We also see if we think
of clinical applications,
there's been many now studies looking
at clinical applications of mindfulness
meditation across a host of Dsm disorders
ranging from anxiety disorders to
depression to even bipolar disorder.
But one of the studies that,
that I'm highlighting today is
looking at substance use and abuse.
So here there's been studies looking
at mindfulness meditation as a way to
actually curb cigarette craving and use.
So what you see here is if you
compare mindfulness training, um,
what you find is that it actually is
associated with Gregor smoking abstinence.
Um, so it's really fascinating when you
look at this work again done by Judson
brewer here at Yale University. And
additional work has filed this up by Heti,
Cobra and colleagues as well.
Looking at how meditation actually is
associated reductions and craving for a
whole host of substances
outside of simply cigarette use.
So what we're seeing is that
it helps curb addictions,
helps us retain control over some of
these impulses we have towards using
substances that may
ultimately be harmful for us.
So here's an example of one study that
Heady Cobra was an author on showing that
mindful attention reduces neural and
self reported cue induced craving and
smokers.
So again,
this is further suggesting that we're
not only seeing reduction than self
reported craving to different types
of substances such as cigarettes,
but we're also seeing parallel and
robust patterns when we look at neural
patterns of activation and response to
cues that would normally elicit craving
in smokers such as cues of a cigarette.
Now if you look at this here, um, for
those of you that like to watch ted talks,
um, I highly recommend this Ted talk on
the habits of happiness. Um, this, this,
this man is,
is a Buddhist monk at author and
photographer and has often been called the
happiest man in the world. He has a
really interesting quote where he says,
mine training is based on the idea
that two opposite mental factors cannot
happen at the same time.
You could go from love to hate,
but you cannot at the same time towards
the same object or the same person want
to harm and wants to do good.
So this is one of the most popular talks
you can find on the Ted talks and I
highly recommend watching it if you're
interested in learning more about some of
these core principles
underlying mindfulness.
I'm from a very scholarly Buddhist monk,
author as well as photographer.
Yeah,
so we've talked a little bit
about mindfulness, what it is,
what are the mechanisms?
We've sort of scratched the surface of
some of the key empirical findings that
have associated mindfulness with reduced
emotional or activity changes in neural
reactivity and even changes in craving
for substances as well as knowing that
it's associated with reductions in
symptoms severity such as depression,
vulnerability. What I now want to do is
turn to our takeaway questions for today.
The first question asks,
how would you define mindfulness and
what are the four critical ingredients?
Second,
what does the support of evidence that
suggests that mindfulness can actually
alter patterns of self
reported emotional reactivity.
And third,
what is the supportive evidence that
suggests mindfulness can also alter
patterns of neural activity that are
commonly associated with emotionality as
well as cognitive control
over our emotions.
So now we'll turn to our experts
in emotion interview series.
Okay,
today we'll be speaking with doctor
heady Cobar on craving and mindfulness,
Dr Cobras and assistant professor in
the Department of Psychiatry at the Yale
University School of Medicine,
as well as the director of the clinical
and affective neuroscience lab and
director of research at the Yale
therapeutic neuroscience clinic.
Doctor Cobras interest are focused on
using a multilevel approach to understand
the use of cognitive
strategies to regulate emotion.
She's used both behavioral and neuro
imaging tools to better understand the
psychological and biological mechanisms
that underlie processes related to
emotion craving,
the cog cognitive regulation of emotion
and craving in both healthy adult as
well as psychiatric populations.
Dr Cobra has received several honors,
including the National Institute of Drug
Abuse, women and Gender Travel Award,
the National Institute of Drug Abuse,
early career investigator travel award,
and the Yale Center for Clinical
Investigation Scholar Award.
Her work has also been
mentioned in the popular media,
including outlets such as
CNN, ABC News, La Times,
and US news and world report.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion
interview with doctor heady. Cohbar.